can you explain this whole Trump thing
right here well what this part no where
we certainly are yeah yeah yeah right so
oh man uh
2005 I want to say oh we're going back
well that's when it starts so Donald
Trump uh he's The Apprentice guy newly
married to Melania yeah
um I believe he's in Aspen he meets up
with a woman named Stormy Daniels seeing
her storm star yes I went and saw her
strippers made a lot of money in Dallas
okay how was it and uh she got on stage
and the guys on the front row put on
their Mega hats I swear to God it was
amazing and uh they were just throwing
making her dance while they were in
their Mega hats it was [__]
unbelievable you know what that's a
win-win situation the guys in the
forever we were wearing masks
okay go on all right so 2005 they have
their trip horse face horse face
call a girl he paid to [__] a horse Ring
like you paid me yeah so that happens
2005 2016 he's running for president
multiple women come out and are trying
to extort and basically extort money
from Trump being like I'm either going
to go to the National Enquirer you got
to pay me Karen McDougall she was a
Playboy model she also got paid off
there was like this whole thing with the
National Enquirer about how they were
burying some of these whatever this is
all 2018 drama so what ends up happening
is that Michael Cohen the lead lawyer
for Trump at that time his personal
attorney agrees to pay her a hundred and
thirty thousand dollars to be quiet okay
Trump then uses the Trump organization
to reimburse Michael Cohen for that
legal payment that payment was recorded
for Legal Services not as a payoff now
two investigations that went into this
one in 2018 when this was initially
looked at was whether this was a federal
campaign Finance violation Cohen
eventually pleads guilty to this payment
because the payment was done explicitly
for the purposes of the Trump 2020
campaign so it should have been reported
to the FEC as a payment that was related
to the 2020 campaign not a personal
expense Mike Michael Cohen plays guilty
here in the southern district of New
York to this charge however Trump is
never charged with a campaign Finance
violation that was the federal crime
okay uh there's a variety of reasons so
number one doj guidance says you're not
allowed to indict a sitting president
but the facts of the case were you would
have to yes you had Michael Cohen's
evidence but he could have made a
convincing case that it had to do with
the personal matter as in he didn't want
to offend his wife as opposed to the
campaign so even though Cohen pled
guilty to it because he directly was the
one who paid it Trump himself legal
ambiguity was already kind of there they
didn't know if they were going to win in
court like like directly you violated
Federal campaign violation because he
could make a credible case that it was a
personal payment what would the credible
case be again that he didn't want to
embarrass his wife Melania and it had
nothing to do with it so
um he could have made that he was like
no this had nothing to do with the
campaign this was like me to save face
in my marriage like that's literally all
you have to I mean Not A Bad Case right
this is something you could make so that
they gave me the case this was personal
so that was the Federal one the state
charge that Alvin Bragg your D.A is
apparently looking at it bringing has
nothing to do with Federal camping
because he has nothing to do with
campaign Finance he is looking at felony
bookkeeping fraud so felony bookkeeping
fraud is statute of limitations for two
years you can extend it up to five years
that person was out of state As Trump
was while he was at the White House he
has to prove that the bookkeeping fraud
that the payment to Michael Cohen was
not only made intentionally with the
purpose of a cover-up but that that
intentional cover-up was in the process
of the while conducting another crime as
in the payment was to cover up a
different crime well the other crime be
well that's the problem which is that a
lot of this hasn't come out because the
secret in the grand jury but it's a very
novel interpretation of the law it's
never actually been prosecuted in New
York state law ever before so that's
number one it's a legal theory of the
case that has never been tried yet we'll
find out if he does get arrested and
indicted how that's going to work two is
that the statute of limitations thing is
a little bit weird because as I said the
statute of limitations two years if
you're in the state up to five years if
you're out so they have to make the case
that he was out of enough time and
they're still barely on the edge of that
because he's been gone like back and
forth as how that's going to be but to
me I just think this is the weakest case
against Trump like legally he faces far
more legal Jeopardy in the Georgia case
that's going on right now which is the
Fulton County D.A uh whatever the fine
2000 votes exactly the pressuring the
state of Georgia's election procedures
he also I mean I don't think the Biden
people can indict him now for the seek
classified documents of course they
found classified documents in this house
but I mean legally that one's probably
the most open and shut case yeah where
they have them like dead to rights on
obstruction of justice so I think it's a
huge mistake for them to try it I don't
know if they're gonna do it I don't
think I don't think they will
I don't think Biden and the Biden
Administration the Democrats want to
indict him why not because I think they
want him to run because that's the only
person they can beat maybe my theory is
the Republicans want him in prison they
want him in church establishments
exactly yeah the establishment because
they're like okay if he's here he's not
going to fracture the Republican vote
DeSantis can go DeSantis can probably
beat Biden right but I think Trump is so
polarizing right now and so toxic that
people will do an anti-trump vote again
and I think that they can beat him I
think if DeSantis runs they got to get
we're going to bite and then run
somebody else maybe I don't actually
know I actually because he was the only
viable alternative Kamal as you know
she's way less positive impossible the
party will never ditch her the party
Elites will never ditch Kamala I think
they've already passed her you can't
ditch her do you don't think no dude the
power of identity politics she's the
first black vice president like never
they keep they'll never be able to do it
really yeah I think she's [__] up
enough where they're like yeah this
girl's an idiot who's your third option
but he's even worse yeah look at look at
have you flown recently I thought that
was the East Palestine thing doing bro I
thought they did that [__] to him on
purpose I thought it was like yo don't
run no this is how conspiracies it's
like there was a few crashes in a row
and I was like I think Pete was getting
ideas he's like I think you might run
for president
yeah
because right it was the Trap it was
every flight Southwest all shut down for
a week 2021 was a nightmare for air
travel then Southwest Christmas then
East Palestine and then oh FAA don't
forget that one total ground stop yeah
for the entire that was actually crazy
yeah that was the first national Airsoft
since 9 11. shut down like what yeah
yeah so I I don't know that's my little
conspiracy uh the only thing buys these
again or you think if he does run again
you think he wins if he's alive he's
gonna run again I don't know I have no
idea it's one of those words well here's
the weird thing yeah I think that if you
asked people
if their happiness has gone up or down
since Trump I think both Republicans and
Democrats if they could be honest not
ask if you like Biden if he's good if
he's doing a good job or anything just
your overall happiness
despite every possible Calamity
happening in the world I think their
happiness has gone up there's Global
imagine if Trump was in office during
this Bank crash just imagine the
shitstorm that would happen imagine when
uh the transportation ship went down
imagine but because Biden never has an
opinion on anything there's nothing to
push back against right this goes back
to what we were saying earlier about
like a cultural apathy I think what
happens is if you have a present that's
completely detached it's very easy to be
detached to yourself yes I don't need to
know anything he doesn't know anything
right whereas whereas Trump organized
what was the most important story every
single week he's like we're going to
talk about Transformers this week right
we're going to talk about this this week
we're going to talk about that this week
like and the people that hated him
rallied against it that's good and proud
for it the thing is I can make a case
either way so oh I'm not making the
argument whether it's good or bad okay
what I'm saying is that like I think
that there's this this cultural malaise
that we're existing yes I think some
people like it I think there was an
exhaustion of course that's why people
voted for Biden and that's no question
that's why I think if Biden's alive and
he could beat Trump again it's because
it'll be another anti-trump vote I think
of his DeSantis to his point about
fractional party if it's DeSantis either
way the boat's not going to get that
rocked and this guy's more mentally
coherent I yeah there will be less and
there will be less anti-desant as a vote
maybe my thing is I I what I always look
at is one of the issues is two years out
like who the [__] knows seriously the
economy could crash the Ukraine war
could be over the economy could be
booming here's a good case you're Biden
if I was Biden I would be doing
everything I possibly could to bring
Ukraine to an end inflation will go down
gas prices will go down right before the
election yeah I just got a big win
internationally the economy is coming
back I passed the inflation reduction
act these crazy Republicans didn't get
what what they wanted during abortion no
more stop the steal that's a good case I
could make the other case which is he's
too beholden to the neocons escalates
the war in Ukraine it's a [__]
disaster gas is five dollars a gallon
okay welcome back president Trump to
your point
Trump yeah if you ask somebody on
February 2020 who's going to win the
election it wasn't even a question Trump
was going to get reported March 2020 by
30 000 votes we all forget that yeah 30
000 votes across three states they only
lost Georgia by ten thousand yeah if
enough if the same people who voted by
mail in the Republican primary vote in
2020 he wins Georgia the same thing in
Maricopa County and also basically the
same thing in either Pennsylvania
Wisconsin or Michigan that's why I think
though anti-votes are strong the reason
Dems won more states in the midterm
Senate than people thought yes is anti
the anti-abortion they're
anti-antiaborty absolutely correct the
anti-abortion law passed they overturned
role versus Wade yeah which for me it's
just crazy to overturn the Supreme Court
ruling I don't care what it is but well
what about Dred Scott which one is that
one uh the one where they declared that
black men are not citizens of the United
States
[Music]
the one that overturned the Fugitive
Slave Act and uh or sorry the uh
sometimes
what about koramatsu which would upheld
the Japanese internment camps I think it
was like 1942. yeah yeah but yeah that
one's still on the books technically
actually but yeah I think the anti-vote
will still be strong if Trump wins just
I agree with you because it's we they
Democrats have proven the only way they
vote is they hate the guy that's wrong
look that's right they're voting against
something or someone in modern American
history the great landslides have almost
always been negative not positive The
only positive landslide in modern
American history is 1964 election LBJ to
fulfill John F Kennedy's Legacy yeah so
the Nixon Landslide of 68 was a pushback
against the chaos of the Vietnam War the
FDR Landslide is let's get us the [__]
out of the Great Depression the 1980
Landslide of Ronald Reagan and 84 is to
save us from The Nightmare of Jimmy
Carter even Jimmy Carter's election
which was relatively narrow was also
let's just move on from Nixon so it's
almost always been powerful in modern
American history to be the anti-vote
like the move on Party part of the
reason again why I think Biden was so
successful uh but Trump also like I said
that Ukraine case I laid out that's very
possible like we could be in a
full-blown conflict in Europe and Trump
is like I will get us out I mean that's
literally what Eisenhower ran on against
Truman He said I will go to Korea and
I'm gonna get this the [__] out of the
Korean War